as far as maintenance is concerned
lufthansa has already put out a
statement it of course own Germanwings
which operated this flight that it's
maintenance record is impeccable and
that once a plane is inspected as this
one had been apparently yesterday in
disel Dorf there is absolutely nothing
that could be wrong with the plane what
do you think about that statement well I
think that from their point of view
that's a reasonable thing to say
obviously if the maintenance has been
very good and when they go over it and
they do the maintenance they check
everything and they don't find anything
that's that's awry that doesn't mean
that something can't go bad you know in
the X number of hours that the plane
flow flew down to down to Spain and then
back so the investigators obviously
we'll be looking first at the recorders
obviously and that's those are the those
are the most valuable thing that you can
that you can find in an investigation
and they may if something went wrong
with a plane the flight data recorder
will probably indicate or give you an
idea of where you should be looking more
more intensely what could cause such a
quick descent from 38,000 feet to five
or 6,000 feet in eight minutes could
that be an engine failure could it be
colliding with geese I mean what do you
think could cause that kind of descent
you know I just it's very hard to
speculate if something had gone wrong
with the system the air management
system in the aircraft and and you have
you had a risk of of not having enough
oxygen in the air at the cruise altitude
you obviously that's the first thing I
would think of first reason to go into a
serious and quick descent but again
it'll it'll remain to be seen
and who knows I mean it's in the pocket
in the in the cockpit one of the pilots
having a health problem it's just I mean
the number of speculative things you
could come to is almost indefinite and
the images that you're seeing right now
are a rescue team by the crash site
Robert you know there's been a lot of
emphasis recently on cutting costs at
airlines and there seem to be a lot of
crash recently recently from the
Malaysia crash to the Singapore crash do
you think that standards are loosening
and that it's becoming less safe to fly
planes no all right do we just hear
about these these incidents more and to
hit home more because they're so rare
these days well I you know I think
obviously when there is an accident and
and there are thousands and thousands of
operations every day when they're when
there's an accident it's obviously very
visible it's very newsworthy and it
warrants the best investigative process
that can take place and certainly the
Germans and the French are capable of
providing accident investigation that is
as good as anyone's well what can I ask
if they're capable of providing safety
as good as anyone when they're running
an airline on a local oh cost budget I
mean I wonder what you think of this
obviously budget airlines have popped up
and become incredibly popular now
they're all over the place but I'm sure
they can't skimp on something like
maintenance or safety or pilots
experience although I do anyway you've
got to be careful these are budget
airlines in terms of what they charge
the passengers that does not at all
equate to being budget in terms of their
maintenance or the equipment and
operations that they have I wonder about
the experience of their pilots though I
mean how important is that you hear more
and more from maybe this is just
propaganda from pilots unions that are
trying to negotiate better positions
that these airlines are hiring less
experienced pilots because they can pay
them less less money i I don't I have
not seen any evidence of that and you
know I pilots unions are whining all the
time about something but but this
apparently the pilot the captain had
6,000 or 8,000 hours or whatever it was
I mean he was he was not a rookie and
and the Germans standard for for safety
is as good as anyone's yep all right
well I just wanted it's great to have
you here to separate the fact in the
fiction robert Francis former NTSB vice
chairman thanks so much for your time
really appreciate this